aux portes de l'ukraine la russie a
déployé 2500 soldats de plus
des bruits de bottes qui résonne de plus
en plus fort dans l'est du pays une
autre provocation de la russie à 50
kilomètres des frontières
et une présumée incursion dans les
serveurs de l'administration publique
ukrainienne
une cyberattaque a été commise contre
certains sites web gouvernementaux
explique ce porte parole sans qu'aucune
fuite de données ne se soit produit
assure-t-il le régime de vladimir
poutine semblent déterminés à maintenir
la pression sur l'ukraine mais aussi sur
les états unis l'europe et leurs alliés
de l'otan mais ce n'est pas tout ces
manoeuvres pourrait mener à une escalade
encore plus grave
un scénario de déstabilisation dont le
kremlin a le secret pour justifier ses
agissements
nous avons insisté à ça avant 2014
affirme la porte-parole de la maison
blanche en référence à l'annexion de la
crimée par la russie des actes de
sabotage visant accusé l'ukraine de
préparer une attaque imminente contre
les forces russes dans l'est du pays
après une semaine de pourparlers
infructueux avec les états unis et
l'otan la russie semble déterminé à
poursuivre sa politique agressive envers
l'ukraine
notre patience est à bout affirme le
ministre des affaires étrangères russe
qui accuse l'occident de ne pas tenir
ses promesses de non expansion de l'otan
vers l'est des promesses orales que
james baker aurait fait à michael
gorbatchev en 1990 mais pour cet expert
l'ukraine est bien plus qu'un simple
territoire à conquérir ce que nous dit
poutine c'est que l'ukraine est une
partie intégrale de l'identité russe
alors on ne peut pas y avoir de
compromis en mé à
cette cible de pressions la honte est
l'occident puis évidemment on met de la
pression sur sur le crem en créant ce
climat ce climat qui laisse à croire
qu'une guerre
les etats-unis et leurs alliés ont
pourtant été très clair toute agression
envers l'ukraine sera suivi d'une
riposte à tout le moins économique
contre mouscron ici s me cry a traduit
au canada montréal
le développement qu'ils surviennent à la
fin d'une semaine de discussions
intensives entre moscou et l'occident on
en parle avec notre correspondante en
russie donc tamara force est de
constater qu'elles n'ont pas mené à
grand chose ces discussions et à plus
grande marge de manoeuvre j'étais à la
conférence de sergueï lavrov aujourd'hui
à moscou elle duré trois heures et
presque toutes les questions ont porté
sur cette confrontation avec l'occident
et il aurait pété très clairement trois
fois plutôt qu'une la patience de la
russie s'amenuisent il a dit qu'on veut
une réponse écrite et détaillée des
états unis au sujet de nos demandes et
ses demandes elles sont claires elles
sont nettes elles sont précises et
surtout non négociable la russie veut
que le temps c'est son expansion
s'engage à ne jamais admettre l'ukraine
houssen serra et elle veut le retrait
des troupes de l'otan des pays qui
avoisine la russie
la suite il l'a dit très clairement
départ des états unis donc ça ressemble
drôlement à un ultimatum dans la mesure
où on sait déjà que le temps les
etats-unis ont dit non c'est hors de
question
on n'ira pas là donc on a le droit
aujourd'hui je vous dirais de craindre
le pire même si on peut encore éviter
une action militaire est ce la russie ne
s'en cache pas elle a plus de cent mille
soldats déployés un peu partout aux
frontières de l'ukraine et la russie
étudie ses options les états unis leur
côté veulent poursuivre les pourparlers
est ce encore possible à ce stade si
moscou ne vois pas l'utilité de
poursuivre les pourparlers dans les
circonstances actuelles le terrain et
pas assez fertile donc ça cause beaucoup
cette instabilité politique de remous
sur les marchés ici le rouble depuis
jeudi a perdu du poil au pire c'était 3
% de sa valeur face au dollar à mai
c'est sans compter qu'à washington on
prépare au sénat d un projet de loi avec
décence ont extradé sanction
extraordinaire qu'ils attaqueraient non
seulement les banques russes mais
l'entourage de monsieur poutine et le
président lui-même ça aussi ça aide pas
disons à l'atmosphère et aux
négociations donc on nage vraiment dans
des eaux troubles avec une russie qui
veut aujourd'hui réclament un nouveau
pacte de sécurité en europe pour réparer
ce qu'elles considèrent les erreurs du
passé la trahison de l'ouest et de l'eau
côté mais le temps qui refuse de faire
des concessions et monsieur labre a
encore une fois été très clair en
conférence de presse aujourd'hui il a
dit les concessions on en a assez fait
la balle est dans le camp des états unis
on croit qu'avec la bonne volonté il ya
moyen de s'entendre mais on se prépare
pour toute éventualité merci beaucoup à
tamarin à moscou au revoir